it does feel like we have a lot of story
to tell it doesn't feel like there's a
shortage of ideas it's lakes with
cocaine like the israelis do it how'd
you know
i broke time the cast of russian doll is
ready for another season
look at that
while chatting with e.t at the season 2
premiere bash the ensemble says there
wasn't any pressure following their
breakout success we didn't feel any
pressure why would we feel any pressure
yeah whatsoever uh three years to make a
new season that people are waiting for
okay maybe a little pressure i mean yeah
it was really intense and
given everything that happened too i
mean they were they're pretty um unusual
circumstances to work under
um so i'm just so excited that now it
can come out and we can finally just
celebrate
what we made we didn't expect it i think
in the first season to be received as
well as it did i mean not that we
weren't hoping for it um of course we
went in expecting the most but we're
surprised to see so many people connect
i think that
you walk into the second season
requiring a certain amount of
amazingness
with that and i i truly believe natasha
rose to it i really do yeah nadia is a
bit of an uh anti-hero so i think
modeled and my favorite television
character uh andy sipowitz dennis franz
my boyfriend uh and so but i think you
often see that with male characters that
they have this sort of uh complexity
where they do have a family unit but
back of that they have a whole host of
dreams and problems and
weirdly i think that uh the female
writers room all of us being so
bogged down we don't really think of her
as a girl at all in some way which is
the weird flip of it it's weirdly to
just try to make her a person and while
the netflix series hasn't been renewed
for season three just yet the cast still
has some dream guest stars in mind a lot
of the cast is dark and eerie like their
personalities maybe jock queen phoenix
oh my gosh
alfred witter just popped in my head i
mean that's what's so great about this
show truly anything can happen for the
next season so i'm a dream guest star i
mean i want to say
gosh what about steve buscemi i'm going
to say
steve buscemi i would love to see like
my rudolph just because of the whole
clique and just the energy i think she'd
bring to the show i didn't choose you
the first time
but
i guess that's just how the story goes
huh mom while the fans are praising this
season's climax natasha says there's
more than enough potential for a third
go-around yeah i do think it's funny
that uh
i i appreciate uh
the the zest of the zeitgeist uh
letting us know
what there should be or there shouldn't
be but i do think that uh it feels like
for for uh amy and leslie and i i just
feel like we have a lot of story to tell
and maybe there will be maybe there
won't but it's uh it doesn't feel like
there's a shortage of ideas
[Music]